>> I'm delighted to welcome
Ann to MSR Redmond. I knew it.
Ann is an assistant professor
at the Department of
Psychology at Berkeley.
She heads the CCN lab,
Computational Cognitive Neuroscience.
Did I get the order right?
>> Yeah.
>> She has done amazing work.
In speaking to her today morning,
I realized that she offers
a complementary perspective to what
Manuel Blum spoke about
just a couple of weeks back on
the conscious Turing Machines.
Well, here is a cognitive
scientist who will give
us the cognitive science viewpoint
on working memory.
I do remember reading one of your
papers a few years back on how
much of reinforcement
learning in humans is just
working memory versus actual
reinforcement learning.
I'm very eager to hear more about
bringing RL computation,
Neural Coding together.
>> Right.
>> Looking forward to the talk.
>> Great. Thank you very much.
Thank you for the invitation.
It's very exciting for me to be here.
I don't get that often a chance
to talk to people in
AI and I think we could all
benefit more from
our discussion often.
So, that's really great.
So, I prepared a talk
that has two parts,
and that is supposed to be one hour,
but I was told to expect
lots of interruptions,
which I really welcome.
It's always hard to make
sure in advance what people
know and what don't,
so please, feel free to
ask questions at anytime.
I made it so that if we
go through the first part,
I'll be very happy.
So, that's good. Okay. All right.
So, in my lab,
my lab is called Computational
Cognitive Neuroscience,
and I really tried to take
the three angles to
try and to understand
how humans make decisions and learn.
I focus on reinforcement learning.
I'm going to very quickly
define that because I think it
means different things to
different communities actually.
So, there's the whole AI community
who means something AI
and modularly apply math and
computer science community
who means something with
reinforcement learning.
There's the Cognitive
crowd who looks at
behavior and mean something else,
and does the Neuroscience crowd
who means something else again.
Of course, this is all related,
but it's also different in
very important ways that I'm
going to try to talk about.
Okay. So, I probably don't need to
explain this part to
you guys, the computation.
The way I think of it, at least
from my external point of view,
is that it's really a class
of learning algorithm that
are trying to find policies
that maximize a fairly
specific cost function
or minimize a cost function.
You're going to be fairly
disappointed in the kind
of reinforcement learning
algorithm that I use.
It's essentially the simplest.
You can think of the one where
you get an estimate of the value,
gets to reward prediction error
and update your values.
So, most of my reinforcement learning
algorithms are going to
be limited to that today.
Sorry. In the Psychology Cognition
Cognitive Science field,
we think of reinforcement
learning as a set of behaviors,
and also a set of tasks that
we use to probe this behavior.
That's everything that
we're essentially
have to learn from feedback
that's either reinforcing
or furnishing
this fair game to being called
reinforcement bit learning.
Okay. So, here I am
giving an example,
it's not even human.
This is a rodent who is
learning a simple bandit task.
The color here tells us
which of two bandits
are the best at a given time.
You see that the size
of the text tells us
whether the animal got a
reward or not for this choice.
You see that the animal learns to
pick green when green is good,
and orange when orange is good, etc.
So, this is the kind of
reinforcement learning
behavior we look at.
What's interesting here is that,
if you plot the aggregated behavior.
So here, it's the dotted line,
I plotted the probability of
choosing either of the bandits.
This can be really
captured super well
by the simple kind of
algorithm we saw before.
So, this is where
the algorithm is coming from.
Computer science have been
helpful in capturing behavior.
So, here we have the action
value for both of the bandits,
and that's capturing
this behavior really well.
Okay. So, because of that people
think of them as related.
The last third of the community
is neuroscientists.
Reinforcement learning
has a very specific place
in the heart of neuroscientists
because it's been one of
the success stories of
computational neuroscience
in the past 20 years.
That's because we identified
a region of the brain,
and a region that has neurons
that encode dopamine,
that happened to encode something
very very close to what we think
of as a reward prediction error.
Is this is something you guys
know or no? Okay. Great, perfect.
So, what I'm plotting here are,
each line is the firing
of a single neuron,
and the top is aggregating
this over multiple trial
of the same type.
What you see here is
an animal getting a reward
and you see that those dopamine
neurons increased the spiking.
So, they seemed to be signaling, "Oh,
something better than I was
expecting happened here."
After a while, the animal
learns to predict this reward.
So, that's we can think
of Pavlov's experiment,
the bell predicts the food,
so that's what CS here means.
When you get that, this is where
you get dopamine signaling.
So, that's a positive
reward prediction error.
Then, when you get the reward,
you're expecting it, and
there's no dopamine signaling.
Then, when the animal was expecting
a reward but did not get it,
there's a deep in signal.
So, this set of neurons seems to be
encoding something exactly what
you would want for a
reward prediction.
People have gone further,
looked at the circuits,
seen who dopamine neurons talk to,
and essentially what
they've learned is
that there's a really
well-defined circuits
in the brain that uses
dopamine neurons,
that have this
reward prediction error,
to modulate plasticity between
those neurons that encode
something like a state,
and those neurons that will help
you make a choice down stream,
that seemed to
essentially be encoding
this equation with the help of
dopamine and neurons. Yeah.
>> So, I heard from Brandwatch [inaudible]
who is also like a psychologist,
and he said dopamine is
not yet reported yet,
but it's actually a chemical that's
used to encourage community building.
She said more recent research in
neuroscience actually
points towards this.
So, I was wondering what
you are take on with this?
>> So, definitely it
doesn't encode reward.
You can see it here.
Right? You can see that when
you get to reward here,
you get the signal, and you
want to get a reward here,
you don't get a signal.
That's before those sets of papers,
people full of dopamine
as encoding reward.
After the set of paper,
they feel actually it's more
reward prediction error than reward.
This is a very strongly
established finding.
It's always more
complicated than you think.
It's actually not quite as simple
as reward prediction error
but community building is not
something I've heard before.
It encourages learning, it
encourages associations,
so it encourages plasticity,
so it encourages learning
to associate something
with something else,
maybe that's what you
meant, I don't know.
>> Yeah, the question that I have,
this is perhaps is this more of
a coordination and delays or.
>> No. So, people have done
all the experiments on that,
they've tried the causality.
There's many ways in which
you can, for example,
force dogma neurons to fire and then
you see an effect on behavior,
you get people have
really intervene in
all little places of a circuit and
this is a very strong finding.
It's more complicated than none.
This very simple story,
but if you think of
your Taylor expansion,
the first-degree it's right.
For sure. After that it might
be a bit off, but okay.
So, we have a circuit that's
implementing this kind
of algorithm in first approximation.
So, again, that's a place where
people have said,
"Well, it's amazing,
you can take an algorithm for
computer science and
explain the brain."
So, because of that, because
of this successful link
between those three things
people have tended to think of
reinforcement learning
as one thing only
and even though the field
has actually no all the time
that it was not right,
that there's lots of
other thing that we should
think about so, for example,
when you think of the brain
including this algorithm,
you never say anywhere,
what the state-space or
what the action spaces
over which this equation
operates, okay.
We don't know that and
it's probable that
another brain region for example
is responsible for that.
That this might have
very important consequences
for how we learn, etc.
This algorithm we have here is
optimizing something
fairly specific, right?
This expected value of the sum
of future discounted rewards.
But, it's very possible,
so that part of
your behavior is driven by
other kinds of cost functions
or benefit functions,
in which case we would want
to make good use of all the kind
of algorithms, okay?
So, that's why I tried
to understand is,
if we want to understand
human learning
or animal learning for that matter,
we need to think of
those other pieces both in
the brain in computation.
So, what I want to try to do today is
to give you two examples of this,
one is on transfer generalization
and the other one is on how
two different systems
contribute to the behavior
of learning in humans
focusing on working memory.
I'm actually going to start with
the second one because I think
you will be very
interested in this one
especially given what
I did told me off
your previous talk and
if we have time we can
talk about the other one,
but it's okay if we just do
a first one, second one I guess.
Okay. So, let me introduce
this: the circuit we have
talked about earlier that
implements reinforcement
learning system is
a very well understood memory and
learning system in the brain,
so here you have
a brain cut like this,
you have the cortex
in green and then you
have elements under the cortex
deeper in the brain
that are the bulb are
crucial for doing this
reinforcement learning computation.
Okay. So, this is one system,
one network that we know works
well for doing
reinforcement learning.
However, the psychologists
have known for a very,
very long time that we
have other memory systems.
For example, we have
episodic memory that's encoded
in this different structure,
the hippocampus, episodic memory,
people give the example usually
of it's the kind of memory
you use to remember where
you parked this morning,
you can know it very precisely,
it doesn't have to interfere
with what you parked yesterday,
but then when you don't
need it you probably won't
remember it anymore, okay?
Then, there's another memory system,
working memory so apparently,
you guys, heard about this
last week or two weeks ago.
Working memory is slightly different.
It's this system where you
actively try to remember
something and you can do that
for only a very little amount
of information for
a very short amount of time,
and it's going to be very
subject to interference, okay?
So, that's the classic
example here is
a phone number that you have to
actively remember until
you use it and then it
disappears very quickly
from your memory.
Okay, so we have
all three systems and
the first major question is we have
three memory systems and
we only make a single decision
at a given time
and so we have to
understand how they work
together when we're
learning to figure out,
to make us make choices, okay.
So, this first system is you
can think of it maybe as
the deep reinforcement
learning systems
that have taken over AI RL recently,
they seemed to be doing
very analogous computations.
Long-term memory or
episodic memory has
also recently made a bed of a foray
into the AI reinforcement
learning domain,
so here I'm deciding two papers,
but I know you guys also have
your own research that includes this.
But, I have not seen
any evidence that
the AI community is
thinking much about
what working memory is
contributing to learning.
So, I love to be
contradicted, by the way.
>> It could simply say that LSTM
are an example of working memory.
>> They have infinite capacity.
>> Pardon me?
>> They have essentially
infinite capacity, right?
So, in that sense they're
very not working memory.
>> Well, in practice though it's
sparse smaller than infinite.
It's just a few tens of
climbing steps, frankly speaking.
>> Right. I asked him this aspect
of active maintenance,
in the sense, and integration.
I think there are a few crucial
differences with working memory.
So, working memory, we think of
it as being able to maintain
very precisely one piece of
information on its own or
a few pieces of information,
which I think is fairly distinct
in the sense of what
else things are doing
in integrating everything in
the space that we're not
completely sure exactly.
What information it
has in the end, right?
>> I think there is something
that's been demonstrated
with all these chances
that cannot do and that is
store novel association so that it
maintain goals for a certain period
of time in a flexible way.
They only store the types
of information that have
been trained over hundreds
of thousands of time steps.
>> Right, and also when I
think of working memory as
something that's
an internal representation
over which we can operate.
So for example, I might give you
a number and another number
and make you remember then,
after I ask you,
give me the product of them
which in case you have to
operate over them to manipulate
those representations, yes.
>> So, networks that have
explicit external memory stores
that they access by presses that
is missing that attention is that
not a case of working memory.
Of course, it's not intended
to have limitations
as working memory.
But it is something
that maintains only
what's at being operated on.
Yes, so I think it might be related
in a sense. I think you're right.
The question I have so
far is, for some reason,
we have this limitation
and it could be
a true limitation or
it could be something
useful to human cognition,
and if it is,
I haven't seen this built into
AI but if you know about, yes.
>> The attention models,
but also the previous
for working memory,
they all have this feel
of actually doing reason,
explaining a way which is what
you don't know what it's going to do.
My question is you try
to go somewhere and read
it and then go forward
and go back, repeat it.
So, you can make instance to
go circles on this and the
working memory thought be
helpful purpose alone,
like that too which is
you keep going back and
forth but the limitation
is I guess there to
promote reasoning rather than
sixth sense kind of guessing.
>> [inaudible] I can't really
relate that well to it but yes.
>> So, thinking of just the
[inaudible] in this picture.
>> Would you mind getting back
to this question at the end?
Because I feel like relating
the work I'm doing to the mall
based from Marcus something that
is actually nearly 99% confidence
this question will come up in
my talk and I feel like it's always
better explain
afterwards than before,
but if you want to come
back to it before that,
I'd be happy to. Yes?
>> So, is there a law for
long term memory in any of this?
>> I'm lumping if it's
long term memory.
>> [inaudible] you promised telling
that style two systems of
critical memory versus memory.
>> So, long term memory in terms
to be very vague term, right?
Episodic memory can be long term and
reinforcement learning can
also create those kind of
long term associations that
can go from being subcortical
to being cortical as I know you know,
and so, I think of
both of those as being
long term contributing at
least to the creation
of long term memories,
whereas this one is very short term.
People who stay in memory will divide
memory into fairly different ways.
So, again, this is an approximation
not to be taken a lot of face value.
Okay, so the one I'm
focusing on right now is
working memory and how it
pace a role in learning.
People haven't actually looked at
that too much in human learning.
Okay, so I've given you
the intuition already but I'm
going to make it more precise.
If you remember when you
were learning how to drive,
you were given a lot of
instructions that you,
if you're a careful student, well,
try to actively keep in
mind at the beginnings.
So, for example, the speed limits,
remembering to signal when turning.
Remembering more obstruct things like
the rules for how to
handle a four-way stop,
or a red light in the US,
and also even more
obstruct things like
how to not kill bicyclists.
Okay. So, you'll try to very
actively remember this.
You will keep this in
your mind, so like,
okay, I need to not
go faster than 25.
At the beginning, what will
invariably happen is that,
you'll forget some of those,
and hopefully the worst
thing that will happen is
that you'll get a ticket for
speeding or something like that.
This is illustrating two ways
in which you're learning.
You're actively maintaining
information and trying to apply it,
that's working memory, and then,
you're also getting feedback when you
mess up or encouragements
if you're doing well,
and that's reinforcement learning.
I think of them as being at two
different ends of a trade off.
One, learning incremental
integrating information
in the sense of the value or
the policy that we're
trying to apply.
In that sense, it's inflexible,
but the positive for this is that,
it's a very broad capacity.
You can learn lots of things
with reinforcement learning,
it's robust in the long-term,
and it's fairly effortless.
In the other direction,
working memory is one shot kind
of learning, very fast.
It stores information very
precisely, and it's flexible.
We can operate over operations in
working memory over information,
and the downside is via
its resource or capacity limited.
Amount of information
you can hold is limited,
it's limited in time
too, and it's effortful.
It's something that we have to
engage cognitive attention into.
What I wanted to do is try to develop
an experimental protocol
that would help me show that
those work together during
learning and develop
computational models that
will also capture this.
I will explain my
experimental protocol now.
It's actually quite simple.
So, if you were a participant
in this experiment,
you would see an item
on a computer screen,
for example, a pumpkin.
Actually, it's
a perfect season for this,
and then, you will make your
choice by pressing a key,
with one of three keys
on the keyboard,
and then you would get
feedback that would
tell you if you pick
the correct key for this image,
and then you would see another item,
and you would repeat this process.
You would repeat it for
a number of trials and a block.
For example, you would
see the pumpkin and
the green beans 15 times each.
Over time, you would just be using
this feedback information here
to learn to pick the correct
action for each item.
>> There is one correct
action for each item?
>> Yes, there is one correct action.
There's only one correct
action per item.
Correct action currently
required for more than one item.
The feedback is deterministic.
So, if you have a perfect memory,
you try this, you try
that, you try that,
you're done, and then you're perfect.
>> How many images can people see?
>> Perfect question. In some blocks,
people will see two images like this.
In other blocks, you will see three,
four, five up to six images.
Okay, and that's actually
the critical manipulation because
by having a classic reinforcement
learning experiment
while I'm giving feedback in
response to people's choices,
I test the reinforcement
learning part of learning.
So, I see how much the history
of feedback influences choices.
But by manipulating this,
what I call the set size,
and number of images that
people learned about,
I manipulate the load
on working memory.
What is really well-known
about working memory is that,
it maintain that much information.
So, this should affect
differently this block
compared to this block.
Does that make sense?
I'd like to make sure
we're good here.
> > Maybe I missed something just the
user answer after each image,
or after a potentially
long series of image.
>> No, the user answers each time.
>> Maybe you're going
to tell us next what
the criterion is for users
to choose which button,
what it is supposed to.
>> So, at the beginning,
they're going to pick
randomly because they
have no information.
>> They're abandoned?
The user tracker?
>> Exactly, yes. It's
essentially abandoned.
So, a contextual three armbanded.
>> Does the user know that
there's only one correct action?
>> Yes. The instructions
are explicit that
the feedback is truthful,
deterministic but there is
only one correct action that
won't change in the block,
and that information about
ones stimulus is not informative
for the other stimuli.
>> If that's the case, can we
get lucky with the first try,
then perhaps that user should
not be equally evaluated
against someone who have
explored a bit more?
>> Yes, so that's why I do this
many different blocks
that way in average,
you should start at chains.
Unless all is going to be,
noise of course there. Yeah.
>> I think so had a time that's
the assignments are random images,
or do they start
assuming that there is
some logic to this structure?
>> So, humans will
always assume there
is logical structure,
even if they're told.
There isn't. Yeah, I tell
them that they can't infer.
For example, what happens often
is when they are in
the block with three images,
people want to think that there's
a one-to-one mapping
between images and actions.
I tell them that explicitly
is not the case,
that they can't infer that one.
>> But often they shouldn't assume
that the left button is for
vegetables and the right button
is for landscapes. They
shouldn't assume that?
>> No.
>> Because if they do
start looking for logic,
then that's going to affect the whole
experiment later because they'll
be using totally different practice
that we're talking about here.
>> Yeah. That that will
correct itself from feedback,
but I have taken
lots of care to try to
minimize this kind of biases.
For example, we try
to make sure that the images
in the sets are of
the same category and have
no visual structure that will
add them clumped together.
It's completely impossible
to completely get rid of
this kind of reasoning.
That's actually
the second part of my talk
is people search for structure.
>> To make sure there is
no obvious cross-research?
>> Yeah. Anymore questions?
Okay. So, if you take my learning,
super Simple Reinforcement
Learning model
and apply it to this task.
So, this one where you have
reward prediction errors that you
use to update the value of
the stimulus and the key.
It's making a prediction in
this experiment that because
you are learning for one stimulus
completely independently
of the other stimuli.
There is not going to be
any effect offset size.
So, if you simulate this model and
this experiment with
my design input here.
But they're fit to the subjects.
If you plot here the
performance of the model,
so probability choosing the correct
action as a function of.
So, this time.
This is how many times
you've seen a given item.
It's making the prediction
that the set size
doesn't matter. Is that clear?
Right, because it's just
storing the Q value
for the pumpkin completely
independently of the green beans.
Okay. This is an obvious
terrible prediction.
When you look at participants,
this is what it looks like.
People start writing
changed unlike one third
and when they have to learn
two things they're
fairly close to optimal.
They take three tries
and then they get
richer asymptotic behavior and
then the bigger the set size,
the more incremental their overall
learning curve looks like.
Okay. So, this is an effect
that can be accounted by
the classic form of
reinforcement learning that
people usually use and then you can
do all kinds of tricks on this
reinforcement learning models.
For example, you can add forgetting
or you can add interference
or you can add
many different mechanisms and try
to see if you can still force
a single reinforcement
learning model to capture
the behavior and I have
not been successful.
So, this is about the best
you can do if you just
add some forgetting to
the Q values at each trial.
You're going to get
a slight effect of set size,
due to the fact that when
you're learning two things,
you see them every two
trials in average.
Whereas when you're
learning six things,
you see them every six
trials in average.
So, you have more time to forget.
Okay. But it's clearly not capturing
the qualitative pattern
of behavior. Yeah.
>> So, on the white graph that
shows with you two stimuli,
the blue curve, the fast
learning shown there.
Is that because of generalization
between images of two things?
>> No. So, this is the pattern
you expect with perfect memory.
So, this is the first time
you see the pumpkin,
second time you see the pumpkin,
third time you see a pumpkin.
Because you have three keys,
this is the optimal button to have.
So, if you have perfect memory
you'll remember I try this,
I try that, I try that,
and this is the correct way.
>> So, why does perfect memory,
two better with
two stimuli than with six?
>> Well. These are humans.
So, what I think this
is showing is that,
when we're trying to remember
two things this is still within
our working memory capacity which is
able learn to use it perfectly.
So, perfectly remember okay,
this one for the pumpkin and
this one for a green beans.
But as soon as we go
a bit beyond that,
it goes beyond
our working memory capacity.
So, we can't have
that perfect memory.
>> So, that's the stimulus,
just the problems with
the working memory.
>> Yeah. So, the reinforcement
learning is it just that
because alpha is not big
enough it takes longer?
>> Absolutely, yeah. You could
have an alpha that's bigger and
a Softmax temperature that's bigger
and you could have perfect RL.
The parameters are used here are
the best fit parameters
to this behavior.
I don't remember exactly what
it is talking about.
Does that make sense? Yeah.
>> Does that mean that
reinforcement learning is actually
better than the human learning?
>> That's going to
be very dependent on
the environment and I'm going
to speak about that later.
But but probably not
because if it was,
then you would expect that when
you're within your capacity,
you will be doing worse
than when you're outside,
when you're using
reinforcement learning.
>> If you take for the
most of the cases,
at least above four, four stimulus.
>> Yeah.
>> Stimuli. RL, does
better than humans.
>> Oh sorry. I see what want,
you're plotting this
compared to this.
>> Yes.
>> This is a game fit with
parameters fit to this.
Right. So, again I could make
this model better or worse.
I could put the decay to zero
and the learning rate to
one and then it would be
learning perfectly, for example.
So, there's no real point
in comparing.
The point of comparing
those two is to say,
the qualitative pattern, the spread,
the way behavior changes with
set size is much more marked in
humans than it is in
the best fitting
reinforcement learning model
that you can have.
So, that makes sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you. Okay. So, the idea
here is that well I think
I'm showing you is that,
I can't explain the behavior
of learning in this task
with only a module that has
reinforcement learning.
I have to count also
for working memory.
Okay. So, to do that,
I developed a model
that has a module and
expect that's reinforcement
learning the same as
before and then that also has
a working memory module
that I'll talk about later.
Then I assume that learning or the
policy that participants end up
taking is a mixture of
the policies of the two experts.
So, it's this idea that we have
those two learning system,
the decision systems and
that they're going to mix,
come together for choice.
Okay. So, the model
of the working memory
comes from what we know
about working memory.
Outside of the domain of learning and
the domain of decision-making. Yeah.
>> So, is that second, the RL works.
>> Yeah.
>> The same what you're
describing moments ago?
>> Yeah.
>> It gives better behavior than
humans a bit in some sense,
it doesn't show the effectiveness
of set size as dramatically.
>> Exactly. It's even simpler.
It's this one.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>>The assumption is that
the pure reinforcement
learning literature
hasn't shown any effect of decay.
So, I think the forgetting is
a property of working memory rather
than reinforcement learning.
Okay. So, what the working
memory is doing is,
I'm going to assume that we
have a fixed number of items,
we can maintain off
in working memory.
So, for example, three
and I'm going to
parameterize that by
a capacity parameter.
Well, this is the way
I am going to model.
This is to say well,
three out of the number
of items I'm trying to
remember are going to be
stored perfectly in working memory
and three are not going to be stored.
I can't do exactly that
for technical reasons.
So, instead what I do
is imagine that working memory
has a perfect policy,
one trial back but
decay over time and
then that the probability that I
will be able to use this item,
for my decision is going to decay
with set size when it
goes below capacity.
Okay. So, it's at maximum if
the number of items I'm trying
to remember is below
capacity and then it
decreases in an inverse way over.
>> So, just the working memory
represents a policy and does
that mean that when we see
an image there in the rectangle
on the left and one of
the three choices
decide that is that's
the correct choice or it's
the choice that the user shows?
>> So, that would be it's
the last trials information.
>> Which maybe wrong.
>> Which may be wrong. Well, it won't
be wrong because the feedback
is deterministic,
but it will remember to not
pick something that was wrong.
>> So it's not the optimal policy.
It's just some information of
what they did and also I guess is
implied that it remembers
whether they were
rewarded or not for that.
>> Yeah. So, it's joining
a bit, all of the S actually.
So, I can go into a bit more detail
behind more of it.
Essentially, our modeling,
the working memory the same
way as I do
the reinforcement learning model
with a learning rate of one.
So, it has this compressed information
but it also has this decay,
which means that the
policy gets worse
the more intervening trials coming.
This tells me how likely I am to use
working memory versus
reinforcement learning
and it decreases with set size,
and this is going to go into
the mixture weight here,
telling me how likely I am to use
working memory versus [inaudible].
Okay. So, this model has
a few free parameters that I
can fit again
two participants behavior.
Then when I have fit
those parameters,
I can simulate them all again
and compare to participants,
and you see that
essentially we capture
the behavior much
better than we did with
the previous reinforcement
learning models.
Okay? So, this is
just one step of showing that
this model is helpful for
understanding human learning and
after many others to validate
the fact that we really
need those two modules
to explain human learning,
but I won't bore you
with details. Yeah.
>> The natural thing for me to
do is the next step would be to
vary another parameter and vary
their own word that somebody
gets from being successful as that,
but I know that in psychology
where experiments
aren't often rewarded.
Have you run that experiment?
>> So, I've run a version
of this experiment,
I actually think I'll
be talking about this.
I've run a version of
this experiment where we do
manipulate the reward we
get for being correct.
So, we still have zero versus
deterministic information as to
whether the output is correct,
and then we vary one
points versus two points
probabilistically and
it's a mixed success
because it's very hard
to make people actually
care about reward
especially in such a long,
participants here do 900 trials.
So, any single point they get
a single trial does not
have very much influenced.
So, we end up seeing that
people are not paying
that much attention to it.
So, we should probably work harder to
try to incentivize those points more,
if we want to go there,
but I haven't done too much more.
>> Since we play with the order
of images now to show that
this really does happen not
only on average like this,
but if you keep on seeing images
that they fall perfectly,
and then there is a drop
in performance and so,
because you can actually predict
more complicated things for
time based on this one.
>> Yeah. So, I think my model for
Q memory so far is
pretty bad actually.
I think it's an average model,
and it's something I'm working on.
It's been very difficult to
find a better prediction of,
so what's difficult for me
right now is to say I have
a capacity of three and I'm
trying to remember six things,
which three am I going to prioritize?
There's no very good information
on there telling
me how this is happening,
and this is something I
can try to look at here,
but it's been actually
extremely difficult to find
any pattern in the way
participants are doing that.
>> But it's how they
behave if they keep on
getting the same three
images for a while,
and then the fourth, and
then the same three for
a while, and then the fifth,
different ways of showing them
information and see how
long it takes them to
learn because then you got
very different model behaviors,
and then even using the
model that you already have.
>> Yeah.
>> You can see what it fits better.
>> Yeah. The primary is that,
so these are all experiments
with thought of doing.
There's many difficulties.
Some of them are that we presume that
actually the weight we
give to working memory.
So I go over this,
but you see that the maximum
here is not one,
with actually a parameter two.
We think that people don't have
a fixed mixture weight even
for a given policy here.
But over time they might say like
as reinforcement learning
becomes better at predicting,
reinforcement learning is
going to learn slower,
but after sometime it's going to have
learnt well and not be
sensitive to decay,
which means it's going to become
a better predictor over time,
at which point because working
memory is [inaudible] ,
we might start choosing
it last even if we can.
So, there are
very complicated dynamics
in time actually happening there,
which is why it's more
complicated than it
looks like to actually understand
well what working
memory is like. Yeah.
>> Have you looked at just with
existing data how the probability
of being correct varies with
the amount of time since they've
seen that particular image?
>> Absolutely, yeah.
It's in the paper.
I didn't put it in this presentation,
but there's a big effect
of delay that
interacts both with
time and with set size.
So, the effect of delay is
bigger in higher set sizes.
So, there's more forgetting and it
disappears over time which
we think of as a marker of
people stopping using working
memory and starting
using parallel instead.
>> So it seems like we're
assuming that people are
exploring randomly if they
haven't seen an image before.
>> Yeah, that's
the baseline assumption.
>> Do we know if people are doing,
so one alternative way that I
can see someone trying to
approach a problem like this
which might make it easier to
remember what you've done in
the past would be the basically
systematically exploring.
So rather than actually
choosing randomly.
You could just say if I haven't
seen it before, I hit key one,
I've seen it before, I hit key two,
and I know I have to
choose cycles then.
>> So, people definitely do that.
There's actually
a great paper by someone in
Germany that's actually
not publish it,
but on bioRxiv, who
was looking a bit more
precisely at this kind
of systematic equation.
That's definitely happening.
I'm not modeling it here
for a couple of reasons.
One is that there's massive
individual differences there,
and so you have to end up
like saying like a quarter of
my participants do this left to right
and a quarter do this
right to left sweep.
So it probably accounts for some of
the variants by it probably does not
modify the key finding of interests
which is that working memory,
the load effects, the
learning which is why that's
something we have to get
used to when we model
human learning is that there's
always going to be more to it,
and your model is never
going to be good.
So you have to focus
on specific aspects,
and think of the scale of
confounds and whether or not they
would influence on
your finding and this
is the kind of thing I think
which is very interesting,
but won't really have
downstream effects on
the conclusions I draw.
>> Just curious about any impact
on the efficiency of the working
memory because it simply do that.
>> Probably. Yeah, it's possible.
Yeah, so it might make working
more a bit less efficient.
Okay. So, one way we can try
to confirm that this is real
and related to the brain is
to go look at neural signal.
So, this is me wearing an EEG cap.
Do you guys know about EEG at all?
Okay. Great. So, I can give
you the two-line summary.
EEG, it's those electrodes
that are on the scalp.
It's completely painless,
perfectly super safe.
It just measures electrical activity
on the scalp that is generated
by activity inside the brain.
EEG is great for being
super precise in time,
so you can resolve things at
the millisecond precision.
It's terrible to know where
things are happening,
so you should just
not conclude anything
about location in
the brain based on that,
but it tells us if
the neural signal is sensitive
to a given signal and when,
and that can be very
informative already
about what computations are
happening in the brain.
Okay. It's a tiny signal and
the signal to noise ratio is terrible
which is why we need lots of trials,
and you end up getting
something that looks like this.
So, time zero is
your event of interest.
For example, the presentation
of a stimulus here,
and then you get a squiggly line
that represents the change in
voltage as a response
to the stimulus.
This is seconds, so you see that
things are happening at
100, 200, 300 milliseconds.
Reaction times are
somewhere around here.
Okay, when people make their actions.
So, we can look at
what's happening in
the decision process
before the decision.
Okay. I can look at this.
So, this is average over 450 trials.
You can look at
every single trial here.
So, this is the same thing
just color-coded the voltage,
each line is a trial and
the x-axis is time again.
Okay. When you see it this way,
you see that there is signal,
you see this deep here
and there's a peak here,
that's fairly repeated
and we think that this
corresponds to important
computations in the brain.
Okay? But there's also
lots of noise obviously.
Okay. So, I can take this signal,
I have this is a fairly big data,
this is a single electrode here.
I have this 464 different
electrodes over the brain,
and I can try to say, "Well,
when I look at the signal,
is there anywhere in the signal
that is related to my two experts?
My reinforcement learning experts
and my working memory expert".
Okay. So to do that,
I can extract from
the model components that
relate to the computations.
So for example, the Q values or
the reward prediction errors of
the reinforcement length signal
and for working memory,
I can just look at the
set size for example,
because that's something that
should matter for working memory.
Okay. So, I can take those
variables for each trial,
and I can just try to do
multiple regressions essentially.
So, try to explain the voltage
across all trials for
a given time point and
electrode as a function
of those predictors
that I know matter.
Does that makes sense?
Okay. So, when I do that,
I end up with a regression
weight that tells me
how well given regressor
explains a signal at a time
and a point of interest,
and then try to see how
consistent this is across
participants across
time and electrodes.
Okay. So, that's the method.
So, what I'm going to
plot here is the results.
So, from the time the stimulus
to the time of the choice here,
and focusing it on
the reinforcement learning process
or the working memory process.
So, when I do that,
around 300 milliseconds,
I find the number of electrodes here
that are sensitive to
a reinforcement learning process,
specifically here the Q value
predicted by the reinforcement
learning process,
and nowhere in the brain sensitive
to working memory process.
Okay? If I look a bit later
in time at 500 milliseconds,
I find the reverse,
I find lots of
electrodes sensitive to
set size and so putatively
the working memory process and
non to the reinforcement
learning process.
Okay. So, that's
a way of showing that
I've isolated those two processes.
It matches what we know
about the brain that,
reinforcement learning kind of
decisions are easy and fast,
very very automated in a sense,
whereas this is more effortful.
It takes more time
for the brain to do
the computation that
actually apply to it.
Okay. So, it kind of validates in
the way what I've extracted from
the behavior through a model,
relates to the brain.
Did that makes sense? Okay. So, it
shows that we can retrieve
those two processes
and that they're distinct.
But then I can, right.
So, then I can make use of this,
to try to understand
a bit better what
computations are
happening under the hood.
So, that would be, yeah.
So, I'm going to show
you how we do that.
So before that, I'd like to remind
you that I think we've seen
two processes here that are really at
different ends of a trade off.
Working memory is optimized
for storing information
very precisely,
very quickly, but not
in the long-term,
whereas RL is optimized for storing
lots of things in
the long run but that takes
more time for it to get there.
Okay. So, the next question
I had in this line of
research was to ask what
their interaction might be?
So first, how they would
decide- how they would compete
for choice in a sense,
but even more importantly,
how independent those
two processes are.
Usually, when we think
of having two processes
that are experts at
different ends of a trade off,
we want them to be as independent
as possible so that they can do
their own job well and then be
used whenever it's more
useful for them to be used.
So, I tried to see if
that was the case,
or if there was an
interaction between them.
To do that, I'm going to
focus again on those signals.
So, here, this is an average signal.
This is just saying that,
the signal in the brain is
correlated with the activity of the
predicted by the reinforcement
learning model in this task.
I can do the same thing when
the participants gets feedback,
and I find an area of the brain,
I shouldn't say that,
I find some signals
in the brain that are
related to the reward
prediction error at feedback.
Okay. So, I'm going to take
those signals and I am going
to look at them a bit more
carefully and see how they evolve
as a function of learning.
Again, if reinforcement learning
and working memory are independent,
then those signals that I think
relate to reinforcement learning,
should also be independent of
working memory processes and in
particular they should be
independent of set size.
Okay. So, if this is really
representing the reinforcement
learning systems,
Q value, then it should
look something like this.
Right? It should look like
something that goes up with
past rewards and
independently of set size.
For our prediction error
it should help us go
down with past rewards and then
and be independent of set
size. So, that makes sense?
The premise here? Okay.
So, I can look at that.
I can just extract
the signal at each trial,
and then re-plot it differently.
So, what I'm plotting here
is a neural learning curve
in the sense.
So, it's for signal that is related,
that is in this region that's
sensitive to reinforcement
learning processes.
Plotting it as a function of
how many previous rewards
the participant has experienced
for the current image so far.
What you see is that this goes up.
That's what you expect of a Q value.
So, that's the way I
selected the signal.
So, that's normal that we see this.
But what you see is that,
it goes up more slowly,
for the lower set sizes or
the easiest learning problem
than for the harder one.
Okay? So that, could be
filled of as a big way.
Essentially, what this
is showing is that,
sorry it's not drops, is increases.
Sorry this line is wrong.
So the EG Q-value signal increases
slower for low set sizes
than for high set sizes.
So, the way we could
interpret this is that,
somehow in low set sizes,
we're using working
memory for learning,
we can because it's within capacity,
and maybe somehow this is blocking
the reinforcement learning.
Okay. This is what will happen
if you had a lower learning rate
or something like that.
But then, I looked at the same thing
at the time of feedback,
the reward prediction error,
and if we're imagining
that we are blocking
the reinforcement learning signal,
then the reward prediction error
should remain high.
Right? Because you're not learning.
Instead what we're saying is that,
the reward prediction errors do drop,
the signals in the brain
that code prediction errors
do drop with an experience of reward,
but they drop faster for low set
sizes than for high set size.
Okay. So, it can be
that working memory is blocking RL,
otherwise we would
expect the opposite.
We would expect those purple line
here to be over the orange line,
instead what it looks
like here is that,
this is dropping faster
for the things that are
being learned faster.
Okay. So, it looks like actually,
working memory knows what
the outcome should be
and seems to be contributing to
the computation of this
reward prediction error.
Saying like", Pick this
action for the pumpkin,
I know I'm going to get
rewarded". Okay? Yeah.
>> It's not just that
it drops faster,
it's that for five and six images
all of it's everywhere higher too.
Right? It's not just,
it's not that everything
has the same mean
at time at the first observation.
>> This is actually not different.
>> Okay.Thanks.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's a good point.
Okay. We actually have
a much more precise statistical
evidence for this,
but I haven't shown here but yeah.
Okay. So, instead of thinking
of reinforcement learning as
this closed loop system that does
its own reward prediction error,
this makes us think of working memory
as contributing to this
reward prediction error.
But it's funny, right? Because
working memory is learning faster,
it's actually going to mess up
with reward prediction error
and make RL run slower. Yeah?
>> Figure there. So, do
we, I already know that,
you would expect
higher activity as measured
here for more learning
rather than lower.
>> No, we would expect the
same here, because here.
>> The same?
>> Yeah, because rewarded
his truly is equated.
So, if reinforcement learning did
not care about set size we should
expect no interaction of
set size with work history.
>> Well I was just referring
to the fact that you said it
was the opposite difference
and you might have expected.
>> This is so that you
might have expected if,
with various small cognitive
accounts like," Oh!
People aren't paying
more attention or it's
easier or it's-" something like that.
>> Could have been easier if it
could correspond to lower signal.
>> Yeah, right yeah.
So, which is why we wanted
to see this was actually
related to behavior.
So, this makes a very clear
prediction which is that,
if the reinforcement
learning signal is being
blunted when working
memory is being used,
essentially it means that the Q
values you're learning are going to
be weaker than they
would be otherwise.
The way we can test that is to do
the same experiment as before.
So, this is showing
the same experiment as before,
where we expect better performance
for low than high set size,
but then we can after a while,
at the end of the experiments
give a surprise
that says or tell people," Oh!
Now you're going to go back
through every image you've seen,
every 80 images you've seen
and you're going to have to
pick the correct choice
and I'm not going to
give you any feedback".
Okay. That's the way to
see what is remaining of
that policy that they've learned
previously and it can't be
working memory anymore,
because it's way beyond
capacity and time ranges
for working memory.
So, in a way that way we can probe
what's remaining in
the reinforcement learning system,
the policy and what this predicts
is that, you should have,
the reinforcement learning
system we have learned
worse in low set size
and so that we will
actually remember less well what
we've performed on
better before than,
vice versa, which is not at
all prediction that people
would normally make.
Okay. So, when I did this experiment,
I got what I was
expecting in learning.
So, this progression of quartiles for
ns=3 versus ns=6 the end of learning,
and here I'm plotting the difference
between say ns=3 and ns=6.
So, this is positive,
that's just the same as before
and then when you do a testing,
you get this reversal,
this nice interaction where,
sets ns=6 performance is actually
better than set size ratio, okay.
So, it completely flips, okay.
So, somehow working memory had
this influence where it's made you,
it's easier for you to
learn a few things at
the beginning but it's made you
learn it less well in the long term.
Okay. So, this and various
other aspects of the neural
computation I haven't shown you,
makes it think that this is
what's happening instead
of computations happening
in closed loop,
the working memory system is
contributing various expectation to
the reward prediction error and in
that sense messing up where
the computations of value
are happening in the
reinforcement learning system.
That makes sense? Okay. So, this
is why I'm at now and
the experiments I'm running now in
my lab are trying to understand,
why this would be happening.
So, it's really a bit confusing
when you think about it,
because the goal of
the reinforcement learning
system is to encode
something strongly in the long-term.
So, its foot off being
effortless and happening
in the background and by having
this interference
here you essentially
preventing reinforcement learning of
being able to do its job, right?
Of being able to do its job,
of letting you remember
well later. Yeah.
>> So, I actually,
I'm not sure that it
says exactly that,
I would think that in
this particular example,
that's what it provides evidence
of but it's unclear that,
were the subjects told,"
Look you're going to
be tested on this text post
and you'll be giving no feedback and
that there's some goal
of you memorizing that".
So, I'm just optimizing for
a system in the short run.
We've seen that it's
actually optimal potentially
to be using my working memory.
>> Yeah.
>> In order to optimize this task.
>> So, to have subsequently
then have a different task.
>> Yeah.
>> It seems like you're moving
the goal posts a little bit.
>> I am yeah, but the question is,
If I'm going to bother
running around by ground,
why should I run it in
a way that's sub-optimal.
If I'm going to be,
because in the short-run,
it would be better to have
a running the normal way,
because it would make you
learn faster wherever you're
working memory fails and in
long-term it would be,
in this experiment,
it will be better to
also have lights around
learn its own way because when you
would be able to remember better.
So, within this experiment,
even if I told participants,
it would in any case be better
to not have working
memory interfere with it,
because if you're
assuming that you can use
working memory without
creating this interference.
>> I mean, you described the
reimbursement learning as costless,
but just because it's not thinking
like conscious thought but,
is there any evidence of
brain functioning and so its costly.
>> Yeah, it's a great question.
I don't have positive
evidence for that.
There's a number of evidence,
there's the number of
indices that make us
think that that's the case.
One of them is that this
is a system that's shared
across lots of species,
it's very old and because
of that we think that it's
a system that's running
in the background,
that you can't just easily
shut off essentially,
and that's linears to one
of our hypothesis actually,
that this might be a way to actually
shut off the system in a way,
in a roundabout way, right.
Like you're saying essentially,
I've predicted this,
don't bother learning it, but
it's still learning, right.
It's just learning with
a prediction error of zero,
essentially and then
the question is well,
in which environment
can I imagine this
being useful to turn off
reinforcement learning?
Okay. So, the questions
we can ask ourselves is,
what is a potential benefit
of turning off working
memory this way,
in this specific way
that we've found?
Why is that maybe,
lacunar radars and just contribute to
this reward prediction
error but actually
contributes to the expectation
of value that our system
has and that may be
this is beneficial even
prior to the learning step,
that might lead to
better performance now.
We've already talked
about those costs.
So, then the question is,
whether reinforcement learning
is job since its job,
the function is
optimizing is to help in
the long run rather
than in the short run,
that's why were we would
be interfering here, okay.
So, it could totally be
sub-optimal byproduct of evolution.
We tend to assume that's
probably not the case
just because evolution,
because we tend to
be proven false when
we think that in psychology.
So, what we are thinking that there
might be environments that are
more realistic in which this
is actually helpful. Yeah.
>> One possible hypothesis
that comes to
mind and I wonder if this fits with
the effect you've seen is that
working memory is typically used to
perform computation that are
delivered to memory in
multiple time steps.
So, in between seeing images-
>> Yeah.
>> -users can be thinking-
>> -what they have just seen,
what they saw a little back
and so that depends on working memory
and yet what they think about
can also be used by the RL path.
>> Yeah. So, you're thinking of, so,
we don't have
very strong evidence that,
yeah, that's a great great idea.
So, the idea is that there could be
offline around happening
in between trials, right.
We actually don't have
great evidence by that's
happening in humans
or even in animals,
but that's something people
think about a lot as
something potentially happening and
then you would be
right, that would be-.
>> What was the time between
averages in your test?
>> It was of the order of the second.
So, it was a fairly fast.
Yeah, it was a fairly
fast-paced experiment.
Participants actually perform
better if we leave them more time.
So, we do think something like
that is probably happening,
but yeah that's a good idea.
Another, an idea that we think
might be happening is that,
working memory is
optimized for learning
fast and being flexible
and so potentially,
the times where you're
best at choosing
working memory hour in
environments that change a lot,
in which case actually
having reinforcement learning
that's inflexible learn,
might actually hurt you because
you might be using this
and having a hard time unlearning
when the environment changes.
So, that might be
a way to adapt better.
So, we're trying to
test this now. Okay.
So, we're definitely not going to
have time for the second part.
So, I'm just going to jump
to my conclusion. Yeah.
>> [inaudible].
>> No, probably not. So, I'm
just going to jump to
my conclusion, I think.
So, if you need one
example of the research
in my lab where I'm
trying to understand what
the computations in what the brain
systems are about contribute to
reinforcement learning in humans
and really the key point
of it is that,
it's very important to think of it
as multiple systems rather than
a simple single system and
multiple systems in interaction.
That might provide
very interesting dynamics
in different environments.
I've benefited a lot from
the research that you guys do,
like cognition and neuroscience
have taken lots of
inspiration from
AI research over time,
like we've been introducing model
based reinforcement learning,
and options hierarchical
reinforcement learning framework,
and partially observable Markov
decision processes and many other
things come directly from
nips and stuff like that.
But, I do think there's
also a potential for
reverse benefits where
thinking of the cognition,
the behavior might inform
potentially better AI.
So for example, working memory
the other example I didn't talk about
was generalization,
attention planning,
exploration, etc., and
the way humans do that
might inform better algorithms.
Also looking at
the brain and seeing how
the brain is implementing those
systems might also tell something.
So, again, I haven't talked
to you about that part of
my research at all, but, for example,
we have these dopaminergic
system that we know is
implementing something like
a reward prediction error
that helps us learn those values.
So, if we learn more
about dopamine and
learn of things it is sensitive to,
that we wouldn't expect
a prey that could be
a window into knowing
what comes as a reward,
what is the reward function that
matters for learning in humans.
So, and people have been doing that,
they've seen like for example
that set goals have effects on
dopamine or that we treat
gains and losses differently,
that uncertainty has some effects
on dopamine or novelty, etc.
So, that are these pieces
of information's are also
fitting that could potentially
fit back into into our guards.
Okay and then I would like to
acknowledge my
collaborators in my lab
and thank you very much
for your great questions.
>> I'm happy to taken.
>> Exactly you gave
in the beginning of
the TD learning relationship
between neural RL and AI RL,
can you think of something
that's the opposite?
Something that turns up in
neural studies that
just doesn't fit very
well or we don't have
the correspondence with AI.
>> Yes. I mean, I can think
of it more in the behavior
than in the brain side of my work,
but that would have been
my second part of my talk, is it.
So, the other half my research is
focused on trying to understand
how humans learn
more interesting behavior,
hierarchical behavior and how
this allows us to generalize.
So, an example, I like to give is,
I've never been in
this room before and
despite that I know perfectly
well how to behave in this room.
It's a conference room,
I have a whole set of behaviors
that's associated with that,
that I can reload
immediately and make use of,
and even if it looked
very different from
any conference room I had seen
before I would know how to do that.
So, there's something very high
level about this inference.
So, part of my work has been to
try to understand how we create
the structure for learning and
something very interesting that
I've been able to show there is that,
it's really a creation
process rather than
a discovery process
that participants,
we were talking about a bit earlier,
that participants search
for structure and often
find more structure than there is
for real and create the structure.
This is a very costly process
and behavior actually
that's something
else I've shown that it has
a cost in how fast we learn,
how efficiently we
make decisions, etc.,
but it comes at a very great benefits
down the line of having created
representations that are flexible
enough that we can generalize
them and transfer them.
Everything you have seen off
generalization and transfer in
AI has been discovery
rather than creation,
so I haven't seen, again,
I might be completely wrong and I
love to be proven wrong actually.
But, I haven't seen
really AI is doing more work for
themselves than they should.
Like creating more complex
representations than they
should as a way
to learn better later
and that's something that
I've seen not just in adults,
but I've seen it in
eight- month old infants
and other people have
seen it in rodents.
So, it seems like a fairly core
important aspects of learning,
of dramatization and you
can think of it also as
exploration because once you have
those high level kind of strategies,
instead of exploring at a low level,
you can explore at
a more strategic level and
in a more organized way.
>> Any AI you could normally
have a network with
larger capacities than required
when it tends to overfit a lot.
So, I don't know how you can
actually encourage
exportation by increasing.
>> I don't know either,
that's your job.
Yeah, I don't know.
I've tried to think about it
and it feels like it
would be really hard.
Yeah. But, it seems like
a really important aspect
of in behavior, so yeah.
>> Since we are working on combining
like modeling with memory I'm
[inaudible] learn together,
I was just curious did
you do any experiments
regarding sequential decision
making tasks rather than
contextual branding tasks
or if not trigger
any insights on how to deal
with these type of changes.
>> Yeah. So, that's kind of
going back to the model based.
Are you thinking about model
based reinforcement learning?
>> Or it doesn't have to be
model based or model free RL,
all kinds of things?
>> Yeah. I haven't done much on
sequential decision making task,
I'm actually doing one right
now that's trying to test
the options hierarchical
reinforcement learning framework
in how humans built options
and it's very promising,
but that's the only sequential
learning task I've done.
The reason I've done that,
is that everybody knows
about model based with more free
reinforcement thing, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, it's actually taking
the computational cognitive
neuroscience community
by as a tsunami like
in the last few years
and people have started
viewing learning as the thing
that has to be either free or
model based reinforcement learning
directly imported from
certain battle like that.
What I've been trying
to show is that it's
really much too crude
of a distinction.
You see in this kind of tasks,
there's no sequential running,
which is can't be any planning,
forward planning.
So, which means that
model based model
free would be doing
exactly the same thing in this task,
and despite that we still find
those really important dissociations.
People studying model based
reinforcement learning
and humans have said,
well it is dependent on working
on it and it is true it is,
but what this shows I think is
that model based
reinforcement learning
is a very big thing that has
many cognitive little
pieces in it and
that it's not this clean dissociation
that the field has been
trying to pretend it is.
So, I'm trying to step
back and be a bit
cleaner even in simple tasks.
Does that answer your question?
>> Yeah. It sounded like
what you were saying about
humans with need for structure
is basically saying that we
also overfit with what
we're trying to learn.
>> It is a bit more than that. Yeah.
>> It's a bit more than that.
So, there's definitely some of that,
so there's this really
cool experiment
that is super simple experiment,
where people just see
a stream of ones and zeros,
I think it's black and white
dots or something like that,
but for all intents and
purposes it's a stream
of binary variable randomly
picked with probably 2.5.
If you just look at
their reaction times,
you see that, if you have one, zero,
one, zero, what people have to
say is press right for
one and zero for less.
So, it's no learning,
no decision line,
like just press as fast as possible,
and following what you
see on the screen.
What you see is that the various
local structure in the sequence,
even though it's random,
it's probably one, zero,
and zero, will be much
faster and spend answering
one than they will be at inserting
zeros after that or if there's 1.1,
they've been much faster
than answering one.
So, in that sense that's
exactly overfitting saying like
this local structure it's more
regular than we think it is,
and we're predicting the next one
based on this very local structure.
That's overfitting and we
would integrate this way too.
The type of thing I do goes
a bit beyond that because we're
essentially creating variables that
don't exist and that
they are not needed.
It's a bit hard to explain without
having introduced the question.
But, it's more than overfitting.
It's creating more structure
than there is out there.
Yeah, it would take
[inaudible] sorry. Yeah?
>> So, in the case where they
were pretty like faster
when they do one,
zero, one zero, and things like that.
>> Yeah.
>> Was there any cost,
some others were they slower?
It goes one zero, one zero, zero?
>> Yes. Yeah. It goes
in both directions and
that's a fairly standard training
is that anywhere you have transfer,
you'll have both positive
and negative transfer.
Like, you'll benefit if
you're in a situation where you
can apply and you have a cost.
>> Yeah, I was going to
say if there wasn't.
>> Yeah, there's real costs.
It's a really important
aspect of this.
There's real costs both
immediately and in the long-term.
I'm sorry.
>> So, if you want to end it,
we don't have to go perform.
Okay I was just thinking,
trying to get more of it
awesome discovery this is creating.
>> Yeah.
>> A lot of the work I have
seen in the AI side of things
at least we focused on
sample complexity and
like why building
these options of these things
could lower sample complexity
over the distribution of tasks.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm curious about
your hypothesis for what
the actual cost function might be
that you're trying to go after.
>> So, yeah. There's
at least three different hypothesis
there that I haven't smashed to
pull it back yet, future work.
One is, so one can be
framed in one of two ways.
One is that we just have
a prior for bubbling
structure and because
we have that prior,
until we're proven wrong,
we'll just end up
building that structure,
and that could reflect
just the statistics of
an environment where we
expect it to be beneficial
in the long run.
Which gets you could frame this as
a cost function that's
the ability minus,
I guess, the ability
to internalize later.
Another one is some kind of
divide and conquer process.
Where, when you build
structure often it allows you
to make multiple simpler choices
rather than one more complex choice.
So, that might be a way
to cut the problem in a way
that's more tractable.
Another is interference
and lowering interference.
Is that if you create
your presentations for
things that are similar,
you might be able to pull those
representations apart a bit
more in such a way that will make it
harder for them to interfere
when you're learning in
slightly similar but context
but that require fairly
kind of similar.
I think of this a lot because this is
a laptop with a French keyboard and I
have a laptop that looks
nearly the same and has
an English keyboard and the
interference between them is horrible.
So, I think that's because
I don't use them equally,
but if I did I would
probably be able to very
quickly switch from one
to the other. Yeah?
>> One specific question about
this additional structure thing
because I think it's
just super fascinating about the way
your whole talk and research
agenda I think is terrific.
Thanks for the talk at Microsoft.
But, it strikes me based upon
the explanation that you just gave,
the additional structure is
a more complicated representation of
the state space in
a reinforcement learning problem.
>> States in action space actually.
>> So, the action state,
the action space as well.
So, could you give
a specific example about how
a human actor might have
a more complicated representation
of the action space,
would it be like
a conditional action space?
So, like two actions
in a row as opposed to
each action being unique.
>> Yeah. This is not
the best slide for that,
but I'm going to try to do that.
>> It's okay.
>> So, sorry,
this is one,
okay, I always have
super simpler Y problems
and I had a great example
with computers and
different operating systems
before and then I came here and
realized there was Linux
and Mac and not Windows
in my presentation,
so I'm a little ashamed of myself.
So, if you're learning this,
your state space could be
those six images and
here we have four actions and you
could just learn
those six associations.
From what I've been
working on showing you
instead is that what
people are more likely to do.
So, you might recognize here that
actually the red and gray shapes
have the same correct action,
is that people will learn,
for example, here in
this case to select rule,
TS here is short for task set,
and task set means rule
essentially or policy if you want.
So, that people will learn to
select a rope in
response to the color,
and then when they have
selected the rope,
they'll use it to set
their policy over shapes,
which is the shape action thing.
So, the way you can think of this
is what action is by
essentially is you
can explain this as
people doing RL over two state
and action spaces in parallel.
So, you have one loop here
that's learning the value
of an action in response on
policy for selecting an action
to response to a shape,
and I'm framing this in terms of
our network in the brain here,
but it doesn't really matter.
In another that's operating in
a more abstract state
and action space.
That's with context rule state
Then, you, of course, have
to create a dependency
between them, but yeah.
So, that's essentially the same
RL computation cannot happen over
those two state and action spaces
in parallel and that will
explain a whole bunch of behavior
in terms of how people learn.
>> So, it seems to me like
the red experimental variation
this world would be how
human decision-makers operate in
dynamic systems that are
rapidly changing versus
those that aren't.
>> Yeah.
>> Because basically these rules
become more costly
in those situations.
>> Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
So, that's going to hit against,
so when you do that you
have to have a way to
identify whether people
are selecting those assets
or those rules to convince
yourself that they are doing
that and that's going
to be even harder.
It's already very hard in
non-moving environments.
It's going to be even harder
in moving environments.
So, that's the point of
studying complex human learning
is that you always
have this trade-off
where you lead more
complex experiments to see
more interesting behavior but
that comes from the drawback
of being very hard to infer what
the participants are doing.
So, but yeah, you're right, yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Let's thank Ann
[inaudible].